El Vaticano se prepara vivir un evento
que marcará la historia de la Iglesia
Católica las autoridades vaticanas
esperan unas cien mil personas este
jueves para la misa del funeral de
Benedicto 16 que iniciará a las nueve y
treinta de la mañana hora local en la
plaza de San Pedro delegaciones de dos
países han sido oficialmente invitadas
la de Italia y de Alemania país natal de
Joseph ratzinger estarán presentes el
presidente y el canciller Alemán
olafones también se esperan otros jefes
de estado y de gobierno en particular
los presidentes de Portugal Polonia
Hungría y eslovenia también el rey de
Bélgica y la reina de España Francia
estará representada por
rialdá ministro del interior y de cultos
el evento también atrae una fuerte
atención mediática cerca de mil
periodistas de 30 países diferentes
están acreditados alrededor de la plaza
que prevé un imponente dispositivo de
seguridad mil agentes policiales
controlan los accesos y el espacio aéreo
alrededor de la plaza de San Pedro
permanecerá cerrado durante la duración
de la misa al final de la cual el ataúd
del sumo pontífice de mérito será
llevado a la Basílica de San Pedro y
luego a las grutas del Vaticano es allí
en donde Benedicto 16 será